what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
tales of the Jedi and today I am joined
by my friend who has an awesome reaction
Channel he is I think he's absolutely
one of the best I love his commentary
and I remember I just remembered your
Clone Wars finality reaction I don't
remember if we cried at the same moment
I remember we cried you covered the all
of it on your channel I I did all of the
final season when Disney brought it back
hey I'd watched it all on my own well
before I had this channel so yeah and by
the way this channel is Omni media this
is Michael P
maybe you guys have heard of him before
it's great at what he does and when he
was asking about tales of the Jedi I was
like you know what why don't we just do
it together because we haven't really
done like a reaction collab together I'm
not gonna put pressure on you and call
you the Star Wars expert or something
like that but I feel like you you'd have
a little bit fresher in your mind than I
would because I was just like one quick
binge through it but either way I'm
excited for it you excited for it oh
yeah man I've really been looking
forward to this one ever since Dave's
been talking about it just kind of like
these little tone poems that he he
really kind of wanted to share that
expanded on these two characters and
then I started to think about it a
little bit the other day I was like no
wait there are two people that both were
disillusioned by the Jedi and left the
order but both went two very different
ways
that's afterwards that's why I was like
what are we gonna do I'm still not over
the fact you just called him Dave
as if he's dude I know I mean I actually
have like a speed time yeah
guys leave a like follow Michael on
omnimedia let's get this show on the
road people let's get it going
[Music]
those are stars I hear there's Wars out
there
[Laughter]
no no no
[Music]
this is gotta be the baby Ahsoka story
[Music]
[Music]
this was like when I was born
a whole village showing up yeah at
Kaiser Hawk Permanente Hospital
[Music]
no
Ahsoka
wow she just knew that yeah just like
Padme automatically was like with all
these space names we're gonna go with
Luke
oh okay
okay all right I'm going right right to
the core there
foreign
gutter Droid I think that's the first
one I've seen
are you sure she is ready it
all right then I meant no offense how
did Ahsoka come out with the accent that
she has
that's a good question
good hunting party
silke
[Music]
one thing I did see like the the
uh voice actress for her mother and this
is the same one that played Aiden uh in
on uh Battlefront 2. oh that's cool
off on the hunt
Ika
[Music]
oh go to the world cats thing called
look like loaf cats but they're like but
they're like red pandaish
instead for luck
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
I really like getting a sense that the
actual culture she comes from I know I I
can't recall really seeing too much of
it
[Music]
yeah I could not look at these things up
close we can leave now thank you they
look like
there's chocolate inside of them
just like this is going to be a Pokemon
in the next game I'm sure
look Asaka everywhere there is life
value it
honor it
Lala life
the the death
thank you
this is where beanies come from pom-poms
yeah
[Music]
huh
those are some cool dandelions
this is how the Last of Us started I was
thinking of the last of us I'm not even
joking
I did not expect them to stand up
mm-hmm
how violent is this going to be
breathe
Kasha
[Music]
I wonder why she has to take Ahsoka with
her I don't know
I was kind of thinking about that when
they kind of started to leave the
village and all that but like I don't
know
it's not like you contributing or
anything if anything she'd be a
detriment to the Hunts lazy baby
[Music]
you must face death Ahsoka
wow it's such an early age
oh that's sad
yeah
I can tell you I wouldn't even know what
the heck's going on at one yeah
foreign
it's cool the first episode's uh
like a tribal Hunter episode yeah I'm
getting like uh it gave me like atreus
and Kratos kind of Vibes never oh hello
I shall carry you and the kaibak
unless you would like to carry him
oh
yeah we killed oh no is Mom gonna die
right now
[Music]
I'm just gonna
horse on it
that thing is chunky
[Music]
oh my God oh my God Mom she is fast holy
[ __ ] holy balls
foreign
[Music]
oh my Lord
that took a turn
you're not a very good Hunter mom can't
see that giant fat ass animal sticking
up on you
dude she is God
hey you gotta give her credit man she's
going at this thing
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
out of all things to predict yeah did
not see that coming no not at all
and
that was wild
[Music]
sir
this is a really nice Beast
unless it's uh taking it taking her to
like feed to the Cubs or that
cover your mouth do you have covered
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this what is this animal's
intention
[Laughter]
oh that's adorable though oh that's cool
[Music]
wow she is fearless we will go out in
force we will not stop until we find her
[Music]
no way
please tell me she's writing it yes
please tell me she's riding it
dude I'm talking about
[Music]
oh man [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Music]
doing my
[Music]
that was unexpected yeah
I'm I am a little emotional right now
has she not been a force baby uh she
would have been a baby snack I think
yeah that must be the implication right
I have to imagine like some sort of like
instinctual Beast control
[Music]
Jedi
Asoka is Jedi
that was a fast conclusion
[Music]
but you couldn't do that with Anakin
Skywalker
couldn't tame that Beast could you
not at all
wow that was that was interesting
I really like that like the pace the the
tone the vibe of it all yeah seen a
little bit of the culture
it's an unexpected type of origin story
I think it's not like obviously a full
origin story yeah it's actually some
ways the most origin because it's a fur
as a baby could have gone farther back
though you know we could have gone to
seen how concept conception stitches
but yeah I I was uh I was surprised by
the the turn it had though I didn't
expect the I don't know whatever kind of
creature that is
um it's not exactly a tiger
not exactly a saber-toothed tiger I
don't know what it was but I wasn't
expecting that and I think that was a
nice turn and and yeah it's like you got
to imagine you know they always say
Force sensitive so you got to be you
know sensitive with your emotions and I
think like capturing it with that sort
of
childlike Wonder of just to be that in
tune with seeing the the good in
something word there's such an innocence
for that to be the connective tissue
throughout the emotion there was it was
nice it was just such a nice like a
type of poetic wondrous tone to it all
and
yeah damn that was I took a really
unexpected turn I was like I don't know
why they're hunting with the baby but I
guess you got to teach this baby about
death at a very early age but yeah yeah
and uh
that exposure early on and that ins like
them instilling that respect in nature
like the the give and take of it all
the push and pull you know
life and death as it was the title
you know they gave life but in order to
survive you know they got to take what
they need to
uh but nothing no more no less
so I like that like you know
they're not hunting out a sport or like
or anything of that it's like it's all
purely for survival
so I I like I like those themes I like
that a lot and
like you're right you're gonna have to
be a Survivor I think is a interesting
way because that's like that's Ahsoka
she's a survivor
and in the face of this creature that
was more than happy to like
eat her
she didn't have any fear and that can be
attributed to maybe her innocent she'd
maybe not didn't know what was going on
but I think like deeper than that it's
it's it's just there with her from the
get-go yeah because like she's not a
character that ever really runs away
from anything in the end and I like that
she just kind of like this thing's like
right there testing her limits and she's
just like Boop oh yeah that was
beautiful I like that a lot that was
great should we watch the next one
sure all right let's do it but yeah guys
all right we're gonna move on to the
next one since there's a few to get
through but that was beautiful
um you guys can subscribe to uh Michael
B omnimedia subscribe to us keep a
lookout for the next one and uh hey you
catch the full interaction watch along
is over at patreon I forgot to mention
that earlier but that's where you could
do it anywho we'll see you all soon
[Music]